[Music]
celebrity is a really mysterious thing
but I don't think anyone fully
understands why are we so interested in
these people who are just people but
somehow have come to embody you know
some greater idea it's not even that
they're great I mean you don't worship
them necessarily because they're more
virtuous than we are or lofty or
something if they're like gods they're
more like the Greek gods you know
they're prone to embarrassing drunken
incidents they say outlandish things but
somehow people just can't seem to look
away from celebrities and it's not
something new although what is new is
the effort to commercialize that fact to
an extent never seen before new I mean
since the 1970s or so the effort to
build entire platforms magazines on
nothing but so everybody by itself is a
development of the of the 20th and 21st
century we've gotten to a point it's
sort of unusual where if you want to get
attention to almost anything you need to
start with the celebrity you know if
you're interested in the problems of
Africa you don't really get people
interested you have Madonna adopt an
orphan now we're talking you know it it
just has become the sign akwonton for
getting attention it's having some kind
of celebrity associated with it when I
was running for office for instance you
know we'd have a important proposal
about corruption or something but when
we brought out Mark Ruffalo to endorse
our candidacy oh now now we're talking
suddenly everybody was there and it is
strange that this has become the way we
organize this incredible important part
of our lives you know new products
whatever it is but it's kind of the way
it is I've read a lot of the literature
on why people are so interested in
celebrities
I think they don't really understand the
most compelling to me where are the
ideas that compare it to this sort of
instinct that is also inherent religion
and that were sort of
looking for transcendence of the normal
that we sort of believe these people
operate on a different plane if you you
know somehow end up running into Tom
Cruise or Tom Hanks or you know and you
may not even care for them as actors I
mean different but somehow I think
there's this effect or Tom Brady I've
now named three times if we like oh my
goodness there they are and maybe your
heart will start to be there's a
biological reaction
it's really quite straight if you hate
the Patriots you might still have a
reaction and you know why that happens
no one really quite understands I think
the people who compare it to this
religious impulse that there is sort of
gods walking on earth not necessarily
magnificent gods but that they exists in
a slightly different realm than we do
there's some something to those theories
because I just can't really understand
it otherwise
you
[Music]